hi this is John Roca for Collider I'm
here with two big dudes in different
ways Brian banks and Tom Shadyac I am so
excited to meet and talk with both you I
just watched the movie again for a
second time it's so so powerful
Tom I want to start with you we know
about your story coming back to a direct
this film what was it about this subject
this script this this person that spoke
to you considering all you had gone
through yourself did you sense a kind of
kinship in Brian's journey to be seen
again as well well very much so uh it
felt like home to me and that reason is
I had changed my home I I had moved from
Los Angeles I come here for business but
I now work and serve in an
underprivileged underserved neighborhood
in Memphis Tennessee South Memphis and I
had met different versions of Brian and
I fell in love with this community with
these kids pulsing with promise and also
promise that had been robbed them that
from them and one form or another and
Brian and I had been on similar journeys
you know a kind of death story for each
of us and and and and our own different
versions of Resurrection and I just
loved how inspiring is you know this
movie I didn't want it I don't want to
do downer movies I believe the soul
always affirms an optimism and he's he's
a he's a living walking breathing
metaphor for an optimistic life well you
look at people might question like why
is a comedy director stepping it takes
them like this but if they go back to
your films you open you always have
these powerfully dramatic moments within
the comedy for example a Nutty Professor
when after Sherman is like embarrassed
at the club that the fact the way he's
fat shamed you haven't ability to and
did you was it nice for you to flex that
muscle fully for a whole movie that was
really well said because not a lot of
people see that they just see you know
the comedy the laughs right but those
laughs are built on drama on dramatic
moments and getting relationships right
on building this story structure you
know you know keeping that taut and
proper and so yeah this was a chance to
say I feel as strongly as I do about
you know the Bruce Almighty films are
right or you know patch Adams I feel as
strongly about that as I do about
Brian's story and and I can shift in
tone and I can create an authentic you
know an authentic experience for an
audience yeah you certainly did that
Brian what is it like for you man this
journey must be crazy but like you
watching your whole life all over again
was it tough to watch it being done and
walk these steps again for yourself even
though you know the goal was ultimately
a beneficial goal yeah yeah it is crazy
it is crazy to be here in this moment
but yeah it's also a much-needed moment
to be in and I'm glad that I am in a
space not just because the film is Brian
banks but this story is a story of so
many people men women you know young
adults wrongful conviction you know
being accused and convicted of something
that you did not do had only as to our
list of victims you know when we put
people behind bars and treat them like
animals for something that they didn't
do so I look at myself in this story
this movie as a message or a lesson some
form of a tool that we can use to to to
gain more insight into one of the many
flaws within our judicial system if not
more than just one but yeah it was it
was a much needed project it was tough
to film tough to see tough to watch
but that doesn't compare to what its
gonna do and change in our system yeah
yeah what are you both if I can ask you
one last final question gonna got to
wrap up what do you both want people to
walk away from this film feeling or
taking home with them yeah well I don't
think they can watch Brian's life and
not be inspired yeah if you have any
sense of openness to your heart her to
your mind you're gonna be inspired by
Brian you know it's the classic story of
being crushed into a diamond
he's the gem stone and he shines the
only shines because he went through a
very dark experience and turned it into
something so I think they're gonna walk
away with it with it within a strong
tangible positivity and then wanting to
do something yeah yeah and what I want
people to walk away
this is that what I experienced and what
I went through what my family went
through it's not okay yeah it's not okay
and it's something that we cannot accept
within our society no one deserves to be
put behind bars in a cage for something
that they didn't do and so I think that
we can no longer sweep this type of
stuff under the rug and allow it to go
unheard that we have to voice it we have
to make people informed we have to if it
takes enraging people in order for them
to get up off the couch and start making
some constructive changes then let's do
that but the the objective is is that no
one's son no one's daughter no one's
mother or father has to experience what
I went through yeah I think one last
thing if I can wrap up here is you can
also go from this film no matter what
you're going through it doesn't mean
it'll last you can find your way out of
it and that's a positive message
nowadays certainly for our society in
our world not allowing one moment in
time to dictate the duration in your
life exactly yeah this is a fantastic
film can't recommend it oh thank you for
taking the time John Roca for Collider
Brian banks watch this thing it'll
change you